John what's in a standard film
distribution contract
wait what's in the standard film
distribution contract well okay it
depends on what the contract there is no
standard film distribution contract
anymore I'd say there's an all rights
deal there's you know aggregation deals
but I guess there are certain terms that
are similar so there's always there's
always term length of term territory
like what territories it covers what
rights you know the rights that are
granted what you know project it covers
and so what rights are granted so
whether it's a television contract a you
know a conventional digital contract and
all rights deal with the obstacle
whatever have you and then you know how
money is paid back and what the
rev-share split is if it's a rep chair
if there's an advance if there's any
kind of guarantees in terms of you know
if there's an mg which is a minimum
guarantee if there is any sort of PNA
guarantee or promise if there's a
certain number of territories or
platforms that are promised you know
those kinds of guarantees then kind of
certain standard terms and conditions
such as warranties you know accounting
provisions notice provisions those kinds
of things but in general it's it's what
the project is what the term is what the
territory is what rights what the
rev-share split is and then what if any
guarantees and then I would say in
addition to all of that what you want to
do is have ways to carve out your own
carve out direct to fan rights within
that part of the rights that you would
give in terms that are not just in terms
of the scope of rights in terms of what
rights territory it is in terms of
digital television but also whether it's
exclusive or non-exclusive and even if
it's exclusive if there's any sort of
drug to that exclusion out of that and
then so John out of those terms you know
how can you negotiate what can you
negotiate
you know what belongs to you what are
you giving away
well you own everything if you're the
copyright holder you own everything and
then what are you giving away what you
decide to give away and what you decide
to give away is what makes sense in
terms of your goals to give away and I
don't say money because money isn't the
goal for everyone so you have to again
figure out what your goals are and you
have to see how this deal fits into
meeting your goals
well how you negotiate depends on how
much the person the entity wants your
film if the entity if there isn't a
great desire on the part of the entity
who's the distribution company acquiring
the film then you don't have really
great leverage you know they might like
it enough in order to put it on their
platform but they may not like it much
more in order they may not give you a
minimum guarantee for instance and so
you know if they really want your film
which is what you know classically
happened at Sundance with bidding wars
when you had multiple entities wanting
your film and then you could negotiate
for more so generally the amount of
power you have and what you can ask for
is determined by essentially how many
people want your project you know and if
only one person wants your project then
you don't have as much leverage
you